what's up guys
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message for monday
march 29th 2021 it's my brother's
birthday tomorrow and i'm in a great
mood
because uh you know i'd been teasing for
a couple weeks at this point that this
was going to be a major
week for locals and i can't i just
can't say too much publicly this
very second however those of you who are
members at reubenreport.locals.com
know what happened it went down on
friday
and we will have more info to share
publicly
over the next couple days although some
of you who are the more
keen internet sleuths may be able to
figure out what's what but lots of good
stuff happening
i'm really in a great mood i hope
everybody had a great weekend uh whether
you
celebrated passover did a couple seders
ate some matzah i'm a little stopped up
or whether you celebrated palm sunday
yesterday or whether you did
absolutely nothing any of those three
would be just fine actually we do have a
really interesting
conversation happening right now without
trolls and bots in the locals community
about the importance
of these stories of these biblical
stories and historical stories
happening right now at
reubenport.locals.com if you want to
check that out and as always
click that subscribe button and that
notification bell we are doing
four stories they're all over the
political map for you today
and yeah i am feeling good today and i'm
highly caffeinated i already did an
interview
got a couple things later it's going to
be a big day people
uh we're going to be talking about joe
biden uh he had megan rapino the soccer
player in the oval office talking about
the gender
wage gap and guys just because you have
purple hair doesn't mean
you know what you're talking about she
got the whole thing wrong we'll get to
that
ted cruz went to the border facility the
place where they're keeping kids in
cages although we don't call that
anymore because orange man is gone
uh and the the worker there that he
caught her on video it's just completely
bananas
we'll get to that then uh you guys
remember the infallible fauchi we
haven't talked about him in a couple
days
uh he has more comments on children with
masks and
much to his chagrin i'm going to show
you some statistics about children
and kovid and you might start realizing
that the infallible fouchy
is quite fallible uh and then finally
and we really debated whether to
to do this story or not there was an
absolutely
horrific carjacking in dc this weekend
and
i think it is worth showing we're gonna
we're gonna show you most of the video
not the most
graphic parts of it uh because i really
wanna focus on how the media only covers
some stories depending on narrative
right so
if they can pin it as a white guy doing
something bad
to brown people then we run with it even
if that narrative is true or not
in this case it didn't fit the narrative
and it's a horrific thing all caught on
video that if the
races of the people had been a little
bit different would be the number one
trending thing and you're not going to
see this story
on on cnn it'll probably not make any
coverage in the new york times or
anything else
before we get to all that i'm actually
thrilled to have a new sponsor today i
just told you guys i'm caffeinated
it's true watch this
and i'm absolutely thrilled to finally
welcome black rifle coffee company
as a new sponsor to the reuben report
you know black rifle coffee company is a
veteran-owned coffee company
serving premium coffee to people who
love america yeah there are still people
who love america
veteran ceo and founder evan hafer spent
over seven years on the ground overseas
with u.s special forces and as a cia
contractor evan even modified his gun
tracks during the invasion of iraq to
grind coffee anywhere
giving back to those who serve is at the
core of black rifle coffee company's
culture
in 2020 black rifle coffee donated more
than six
million cups of coffee to deployed
soldiers law enforcement
and medical workers through their
signature buy a bag give a bag
initiatives
this month black rifle coffee company is
introducing a new line of ready to drink
canned coffee
the new 15 ounce cans come with 300
milligrams of caffeine per can
100 colombian coffee high quality
ingredients
and an energizing blend of mct oil and
amino acids to fuel your energy and
focus for whatever mission lies ahead
whether you're on a big hunt or a
cross-country road trip ready to drink
300 gives you a convenient way
to enjoy your premium coffee when you
don't have the time to
or equipment to make your own brew be
among the first to try the new
300 in two delicious flavors caramel
vanilla and rich mocha order your coffee
today at blackriflecoffee.com
ruben and use promo code ruben for 20
off your first purchase
that's blackriflecoffee.comruben make
your mornings better with black rifle
coffee
and now back to me and i just want to
say i'm thrilled finally that we got
uh black rifle as a sponsor because you
guys know my feelings about coffee
i was buying their coffee anyway and
obviously the message
is just great so uh so please do
here's to you black rifle coffee
all right uh let's talk about uh joe
biden i'm not gonna say anything about
his cognitive abilities today although i
guess i just did at some level
but he had megan rappanau in the oval
office the other day
and megan is on the u.s soccer team and
you may remember after
the big match she sort of became a star
she's got purple hair
i guess she's a lesbian fantastic
but she was in the oval office talking
about the gender
wage gap and there's a lot of stuff to
unpack here so let's take a look at the
video
my first teaching job i was hired and i
made seventy five hundred dollars
and a man was hired the same time and
they offered him
ten thousand dollars i've helped win
four world cup championships and
four olympic gold medals for the united
states despite those wins
i'm still paid less than men who do the
same job that i do
the strength of unequal pay rests on the
notion of unequal value
it is an issue of equity invest in women
then let's talk again when you see the
return it's even tougher for women of
color
yeah and when we talk about equal pay we
always talk about the 80 cents on the
dollar or 85 cents and it's real that's
not
that's not the number it's about 52
cents for
a hispanic no i think there was a huge
seismic shift last year
inequities in our society were sort of
laid very bare
yeah and for sure i think a lot of white
people especially
dropped the innocence part of it
realized
you know we have to do more now we need
to couple it
with the government approach and you
know with bills and legislation
and all of that to go along with the
change that we're seeing in society
oh buzzword palooza equity white
people government solutions my god all
right there's a lot to do here so first
off i just want to
say something about megan rappanau now
first i don't like soccer
i don't care about soccer i'm an
american most of us don't really care
about soccer
nobody can really name five american
soccer players male or female
i think there's a soccer league right we
don't it's not really our sport right we
like football we like basketball we like
baseball
but so be it this isn't about soccer per
se
but i just want you to really think for
a second before we dive into all the
specifics and
and the numbers i'm going to show you
numbers okay you're not going to believe
it numbers and statistics
um the idea that a world cup winning
female soccer player who is treated like
a god no
no doubt has endless endorsements and
plenty of money i assure you
she's got plenty of money and is treated
only like a queen wherever she goes
the idea that she has now decided to
make the fact
the simple fact that male soccer players
make more money
than female soccer soccer players to
make that a real issue
is so dangerous and the reason it's
dangerous
is that men and women are different this
is just the truth
there are an awful lot of men who can
dunk there aren't a lot of women who can
dunk
that's a basketball reference i don't
know what the soccer equivalent or i
guess there's a lot of men who can do a
bicycle kick and maybe not a lot of
women that can do a bicycle kick i'm not
sure i'm not even totally sure what a
bicycle kick is that when you flip over
and it's over your head
i don't know the point is more people go
to see
men's soccer men are generally stronger
and faster and more athletic generally
speaking
the level of competition is higher
that's why if we only had one league
right if we only had one league then
there would be basically no women in
that league
maybe one or two women could make it
into that league but probably not
right i mean think about the wnba would
the best
wnba player be able to make an nba team
roster
99 99.9 percent chance
no whoever the best wnba player in
history was
cynthia cooper i liked her in their mid
90s uh
who or sue ball or whoever it might be
like they would have no chance they
would be a very tiny
weak player in the men's league that
just is that's but by the way then women
can have their own leagues and play
those things but if people don't go to
those games
like think about when remember back in
the day back in my day
people used to attend uh basketball
games you'd go out and you'd buy popcorn
and you'd yell with other people
and you'd paint your face and all sorts
of crazy things i know it's hard to
believe son but we used to do that
well if a lot of people show up to the
mail game or a lot of people watch
the mail game on tv and the ratings go
up thus
advertisers put more money in well then
the teams can pay the players more money
people don't go to wnba games they don't
really watch them they don't really
watch women's soccer that's not to say
nobody does it's not even to say one is
better than the other and it's not to
say men are better than women
we get all that stuff you guys get all
that stuff but the dangerous part here
is that
she's decided with all of the privileges
her words not mine that that she enjoys
in life she gets to play soccer for a
living
any one of us would kill to do what you
love
for a living i get to do it with what i
love for a living it was a lot of work
to get here
but everything being equal i would
rather be in the nba yes i'm 44
i have a blown out uh knee uh acl in my
knee i don't even have an acl on my left
knee i got a bad right ankle i got a bum
shoulder
and i'm only five eleven and a half i'd
like to say i'm six feet but the point
is
you're you're so lucky you get to do
what you want and you've decided
to make the gender pay gap an issue and
by the way the gender pay gap
isn't even an issue so she says
something about it being a 20
uh you know that they're getting
basically 80 cents on the dollar which
joe biden comes back
he says something and for i think he
says for latino women or something it's
51 cents on an hour
uh on on the hour and all this stuff and
it's like well actually
um no that's not true you're not going
to believe this guys christina hoff
summers who you know is
a friend of mine and she has been on the
show she's known as the factual feminist
right here on youtube she wrote a piece
in time magazine a couple years back
let me read it for you directly the 23
gender pay gap is simply the difference
between the average earnings of
all men and women working full-time it
does not account for differences in
occupations
positions education job tenure or
hours worked per week when such relevant
factors are considered
the wage gap narrows to the point of
vanishing
okay so there's a little bit there the
point is men and women choose different
things women are generally more
interested
in people men are generally more
interested in things which is why you
get more women
that are nurses and more men that are
engineers now the social justice
warriors and sweden has a huge problem
with this which
has a total meritocracy where people can
do whatever they want
they now because they allowed people to
do whatever they want just as we allow
people to do it whatever they want here
in america
they said okay everyone do whatever you
want and then still more women became
nurses more men became engineers and now
they're
basically the social justice warriors
are trying to force more women to become
engineers and more men
to become gaylord focker and become
nurses that's not to say there's
anything bad about male nursing
okay but the point is we are just
different also women can have children
that's not something to be shameful of
that's pretty freaking spectacular the
miracle of birth women can do that
people are different immutable
characteristics related to our gender
has some meaning in the world and we all
do different things
men may want to work longer hours for
whatever reason it might you know like
there's hunter-gatherer
aspects to all of this and all of this
stuff but the point is and this is what
christina's saying
when you take what jobs people go into
the type of hours they want
to put into it by the way this all what
what sits underneath all of this is
somehow that
being a mother who stays at home to take
care of the kids
as if somehow that is a negative thing
and this is something the left has been
pushing on us
forever and it simply is not i can tell
you in my family
i'm the oldest of three kids before i
was born
my mom worked and my dad worked then i
was born and then my brother was born
and my sister was born and my mom took
that 15-year chunk and did not work
then when we were all out when we were
all grown up by the time my sister who
i'm 9 years older
than by the time she was old enough my
mom went back to work and it was her
choice
but it was great guess what someone my
mom let us out of the house in the
morning
was home when we got home from school
made us snacks made us dinner
these were all great things the idea
that we whittled the world down into
what you do for a living meaning your
vocation and how much you get paid for
that vocation and
that should be exactly what someone else
gets paid
is just sort of bananas and what is you
know when they say equity so what is she
really saying what is she really saying
here we want equity so what you're
saying is okay so if the men earn all of
the money here
and we're playing here not that many
people come see us we don't earn that
much
we just automatically should be able to
take their money and of course in her
mind in the world of equity
in the world where nothing has value and
you can just take from whoever you want
for whatever reasons you want
and you have a president with dementia
sitting there placating to it ah i said
i wasn't gonna
do any bite and stuff what are you gonna
do um we got a big problem on our hands
um but this more so beyond the
statistics which i think you guys get
the choices which i think you guys get
this more the idea that she's using her
pulpit where she could be doing such
good for for girls if she if she cares
about young girls like wanting to play
soccer and do what they love or whatever
that might be
it's like she could be inspiring so many
people right now
does that sound inspiring what she's
going for there that no i don't get paid
enough money to play soccer
okay and then these idiots sitting in
the white house it's just
oh and then of course the line about
white people of course this is whose
fault really is this people well white
people
because you know white people have been
doing this forever just like this
god these morons guys let's talk about
expressvpn before we get to the next
story you know social media big tech are
bulldozing over our rights and freedoms
until every last voice of dissent has
been silenced it will not stop i think
you know that to be true
are you guys going to be bold enough to
stand in their way now you could just
deactivate all your social media
accounts but that would be giving cancel
culture
cult exactly what they wanted in the
first place instead of letting big tech
sites revoke your right to free speech
why not revoke their right to your data
that's why i chose to protect my online
data using expressvpn
ever wondered how free to access social
media companies make all their money
well by tracking your searches
video history and everything you click
on and then by selling your valuable
data
when you use expressvpn you can
anonymize much of your online presence
by hiding your ip address
that makes your activity much more
difficult to trace and sell to
advertisers what's more expressvpn
encrypts 100 of your data to protect you
from eavesdroppers on your network
and the expressvpn app couldn't be
easier to set up you just tap one button
on your phone or computer and you're
good to go
it's finally time to say no to
censorship and take back your online
privacy with the vpn i trust at
expressvpn.com
ruben and by visiting my link of
expressvpn.comruben you can get
a month sorry you can get three months
of service for free not bad
that's e-x-p-r
reuben expressvpn.comruben to protect
your data today
and now back to me all right guys i want
to talk to you about kids in cages these
were
things that we cared about a couple
months ago you remember uh we had this
orange man and he had these this crazy
hair and a funny way of speaking
and he put kids in cages and people
compared it to auschwitz
and all of these horrific comparisons
that are an erasure
of history but everyone the media was
outraged
even though although this wasn't really
covered on mainstream media it was the
obama administration that had set up
these cages
at that time obama he's a nice good
progressive democrat
he has nice teeth he smiles speaks well
so you know you can do all that stuff
but then we had this orange man for four
years
and people were very upset because he
put kids
in cages and aoc and the rest of the
progressives were constantly screaming
about it well
now joking aside guys we have a
humanitarian crisis
at the border and there are
basically untold numbers of people
trying to break through our border our
southern border
much of it through texas they are being
ushered in told they can be here we're
getting very mixed messages from the
administration
come don't come maybe come hang out for
a little bit we'll see what's going on
but there truly is a border crisis the
media is not trusting it in any way
honestly ted cruz went to the facility
this is either from saturday or from
yesterday i'm not sure uh but he went to
the facility
and this this video is truly
mind-blowing and i just to frame it for
you a little bit
not only watch what's going on behind
him and and these people wrapped up in
what appear to be tin foil to stay warm
and also we're supposed to have uh kovid
right now i thought we're in the middle
of a pandemic and we're supposed to have
you know six foot social distancing and
the rest of it but really listen
to what this woman is saying to ted cruz
this person who works at the facility
what she is saying to ted cruz as he's
all he's doing
is taking video he didn't put him in
cages all right
please give dignity to the people please
give them to the people so you worked
for the commissioner your senior advisor
you were hired two weeks ago and you're
instructed to ask us to
not have any pictures taken here
disrespectful because the political
leadership
at dhs does not want the american people
to know it please respect the rules you
keep standing in front of the pictures
so you don't want the pictures taken
the rules are arbitrary and they're
designed to keep the american people in
dignity and respect
that's all we ask you're asking is this
dignity and respect
please
please
please
please
please please
please
please
please
please please please please please please let
me ask you there there's a i will
carefully ask you sir
there is a pandemic is this respecting
the rights of these people
are you respecting the rights of these
people sir please don't treat the people
you're right
and this is a dangerous place please
don't treat them and your policies
unfortunately are trying to hide them i
understand you were instructed
when 18
is responsible for these conditions
please respect the people with dignity
and respect
and i ask you to respect the people as
well i am respecting you
i am respecting them this is not respect
all right so this is an extraordinary
video and unfortunately
no you're not going to see it on cnn and
you're not going to see it on msnbc and
i don't know that they're going to write
about it in new york times or the rest
of it right
um just to give you a little background
forbes is reporting that there are
over 18 000 migrant kids now
in u.s custody now there's a couple
things that this woman says there
she keeps repeating please give them
dignity please give them respect
now she is the spokesman for the place
that is keeping these people
in cages these are in glass cages they
are wearing
you know these it supposedly keeps you
warm but in effect it looks like
you know tin foil around them we're
supposed to have six foot social
distancing
are we checking if any of these people
have coveted where are we sending them
how long are we keeping them are we just
going to put them into society and then
they'll be allowed to stay and then have
children i mean there's
a gillion things and as i said last week
the issue is not about whether you want
immigrants in the united states or not
we are a nation of immigrants
uh we have an extremely welcoming policy
although it is very odd because you know
the same people who want all the
immigrants to come are also telling us
how horrible
and racist and patriarchal the country
is for some reason they never leave and
they still want everyone
to come here to share in the horror it
doesn't sound that nice frankly
um but she keeps saying please give them
dignity and respect now
is it ted cruz that's not giving them
dignity and respect having them live
like rats
in that cage right that's an overcrowded
mouse cage right there um right that
sort of looks like when you go to petco
and they've got the mice in the cage and
they're just all on top of each other
about to be fed to the snake that's kind
of what that looks like right there
and then she says the line that i really
thought was like the key thing this is
not a zoo
this is not a zoo please treat them with
dignity and respect
you're right because at a zoo you would
never see anything like that you would
never see
50 lions in a cage on top of each other
usually at a zoo you get three
lions sometimes one he's kind of lonely
and he'd like a friend
um this is worse than a zoo and these
are human beings by the way
and her misguided approach to keep
telling crews that he's the one
not offering them dignity and respect
lady you're
working there and i don't mean to make
this about this lady i would say that
our entire
system right now is completely corrupt
there's no accountability
there's there's nobody in charge right
there's nobody you're gonna get an
honest answer from
from this administration but just think
if this was happening under the scary
orange man
would everyone be going bananas would
aoc
be posting this picture outside remember
this one this was aoc
outside of the facility last time now
actually she was just standing in front
of an empty parking lot
and she's wearing and her white and her
face is covered by her hands and she's
very very sad
and we showed this a couple weeks ago
but then the always spectacular
candace owens recreated that image
incredible cannaz owens put on all white
she went
to a largely abandoned parking lot and
also
showed how sad she was aoc has been
virtually silent on this where are any
of the democrats
please show me please someone
i would love to be corrected here please
show me
where trump somehow did something that
was so much
worse than this because remember when
trump did it auschwitz
concentration camps i mean these are the
people that talk about cultural
appropriation they have no problem
appropriating the holocaust
and calling everybody nazis for their
own purposes please
show me how it's it was so much worse
under trump and those cages
are are less bad cages than the cages
uh that we got right now i mean this is
this is absolute
insanity and it's one of those things
the media ain't gonna show you the truth
so
god speed to all of us speaking of not
being told the truth by the media
let's talk about the infallible fouchy
so uh
dr fauci was on face the nation on cbs
yesterday
talking about children playing together
and
well let's take a look so if parents are
vaccinated
they still do need to be concerned about
their unvaccinated children
playing together in groups is that right
yeah the children can clearly wind up
getting infected when we talk about what
you can do when you're vaccinated
you can certainly have members of a
family if the adults are vaccinated
and you're in the home with your child
you don't need to wear a mask and you
can have physical contact
when the children go out into the
community you want them to continue to
wear masks
when they're interacting with groups
from multiple households
oh god guys who's listening to this guy
anymore i'm not a scientician
i am not a math magician i am but a
humble youtuber who is trying
to do something to allow people to live
a little more free than our technocrats
and our scientists who are always
following the science
and where they always end up is locking
us in our houses
we've got a quote here from the aap
about children and covid
children were 0.0 percent
to 0.19 that's point
19 not 19 point 19 percent
of all covid 19 deaths and in 10 states
they reported
zero child deaths
okay now still the infallible fouchy
would like you to keep your kids away
from other kids we know that depression
is raising with kids we've seen all the
things about suicide
we are breaking down the very bonds that
make us human we are social
creatures they know that this is all
nonsense now schools or some schools are
saying
three foot social distancing instead of
six is there any science behind that
of course not it's 80 degrees and sunny
in los
angeles today once again and once again
i can't go
to a restaurant because they're all
still closed i don't know at what point
we just have to all just move on with
our lives i i that's
sort of the conclusion i was thinking
you know when i was uh celebrating
passover this weekend and we did the
seders
you know it's the story of of freedom
through slavery right that's that's the
story of passover and i think
actually on this friday we're working on
booking it now i think we're going to do
a special
on passover and easter and the messages
the important time-tested messages that
we get from these holidays
but i really was thinking about it
during during this passover
and it was a lot of the discussion
around the table about freedom through
slavery like what
what were the egyptians doing what was
the fear of doing he was keeping people
in bondage
in slavery and the people god had a
little something to do with it but the
people
also had to decide and that moses guy
had to decide to lead the people
out of egypt at what point are we going
to lead ourselves out of egypt these
people don't
deserve our attention anymore and i
don't know what that means exactly i
don't know what it means do we have to
build
entirely new institutions and just start
ignoring them
do we really have to balkanize the
united states and they'll be red states
and blue states
and blue people can just live bowing to
the pharaoh forever
and red people will live freely i mean
is that really where we're headed but
but what kind of lunatic you almost i
feel bad actually not what kind of
lunatic
i'll back up a little bit i feel bad
actually for people
that watch these sunday shows and watch
mainstream media and then
and then say okay my children can't play
with other children or now i've been
vaccinated but i still have to wear a
mask
or i'm not going to see grandma one more
time or i'm not going to go to this or
do that and we'll never go to outdoor
concerts again
or we'll get outdoor concerts we'll
never go to indoor concerts again we'll
never go to basketball games anymore
we'll never see people in groups we
won't do anything with our family until
july 4th independence day because it's
so grossly on the nose it's disgusting
in the backyard maybe with some family
members according that was according to
president biden you see what's going on
here guys like
man we gotta we got we got some problems
but
i'm in it with you so uh so that should
be fine we'll we'll keep playing
uh all right so i want to do this last
story and as i said earlier we debated
whether we were going to show this
because you guys know my feelings on
this i'm not doing this show to enrage
you i i'm actually doing the reverse and
i hope
and i actually see most of the messages
well i don't see most of the messages
but most of the messages that i see
or that my guys send me when they scan
things and i i look at everything on
vocals actually
um but but usually you guys tell me that
you're smiling throughout this you're
laughing sometimes
you feel calmer and everything else so i
feel like that's just sort of my general
baseline of how i want to do this show
but every now and again a story comes
across that is just like such an
obvious like version real world version
of so much of what i'm talking about
that even though it's kind of depressing
um we have to show it to you so
so if you don't we're not going to show
you the the guy at the end
who died um and some of you have already
seen this video but this is a video of a
carjacking 13 and 15 year old girls in
dc
carjacking an uber eats driver you're
going to see the carjacking here
and then you're going to hear the crash
that's where we're going to stop and
then i can explain further but if
if you need to just not watch for a
minute this would be the times
to stop and then join in in about 60
seconds
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay so what happened after so those two
girls hijacked this ubereats driver's
car
they tried to steal the car they drove
it they crashed it the guy was in the
car
he was killed he is now dead his name
was muhammad anwar he was
originally from pakistan
now all right i want to talk about the
media part of this but
the reason i showed you this is not it's
not for the clicks and it's not for
the the sensationalism
of it first off it's related to so many
of things we're talking about
i was in dc in december and it was a
ghost town all i saw were homeless
people all over the place
actually i did a video that we posted on
youtube where i was walking around with
kyle
we didn't see any humans finally we saw
three guys they happened to be fans of
mine which was nice but we just saw
homeless people everywhere
it literally looked like the beginning
of a dystopian zombie movie that's what
it looked like
dc has been absolutely destroyed and now
it's even more dystopian because they've
got the barbed wire everywhere and
fencing
and everything else i mean it's it's all
just ridiculous um but this has
something to do with policing right so
at first it's like
there's just we know that crime is
rampant right now in virtually every
progressive city
crime is on the rise in san francisco in
portland which is completely under
attack right now we didn't even cover it
but this weekend there were more attacks
on the
federal courthouse in portland like just
craziness all over the place
l.a by the way i think maybe we'll cover
this tomorrow we're just running out of
time today but la now is announcing i
think they're putting another 32 million
into policing because after they cut
the policing you're not going to believe
what's happened over the last couple
months do i even have to finish the
sentence i mean i think you guys get it
in any event these two girls they hijack
the car
the car crashes he dies you can actually
see in the full video which we didn't
show you that he is breathing and he's
on
you know laying down for a little bit
nobody's helping him then some police
get involved and they grab the girls but
nobody's helping the guy
one of the girls she's yelling about her
phone that's in the flipped car as this
man is laying there dying
now the reason i'm showing you all of
this is because i want to talk about the
media angle of it
this was the main driver of it so do you
remember about what was it about 10 days
ago or so
barely and it's hard to remember things
from 10 days ago because that's part of
the process here we just keep memory
holding things and
the media just keeps spinning and
spinning and spinning and spinning but
you remember there was the shooting
in atlanta of the massage parlors
and it happened to be a 21 year old
white kid who did it
he says and law enforcement is saying
that it was because he had a sex
addiction and he just went to shoot
people he shot
eight people six of them happened to be
asian two of them were white
but the media ran with and let's show
the headline this is the cnn headline on
it
white supremacy and hate are haunting
asian americans now there was
literally no evidence to prove that this
had anything to do with white supremacy
or that he was a white supremacist
or anything else now again you guys all
know that it's actually the left
the woke left that is racist against
asian people
with quotas and keeping them out of
schools and jobs and things of that
nature
but that was the headline okay so a
white guy
shot six asian people and two white
people and it fit it fit the narrative
they wanted to craft which is that this
is about white supremacy
hunting down asian americans now
yesterday what happened was
those happen to be two young black girls
and they
killed a pakistani man now his name's
muhammad so i assume he
probably was muslim it's actually
completely irrelevant to me
but i think we know what would happen if
it was two white people that say killed
a man named muhammad
okay but listen to the headline on cnn
from yesterday about this
police said girls 13 and 15 assaulted an
uber eats driver with a taser while
carjacking him
which led to an accident in which he was
fatally injured
i just uh i know chris isn't going to be
happy with me
[ __ ] you cnn [ __ ] you
the dishonest drivel that you are
pushing
on the american people is actually evil
at this point this type of fake news and
that is what this is
is actually driving a wedge in our
ability to have a functional decent
society
let me read that headline again police
said
girls 13 and 15 assaulted an uber
ubereats driver
with a taser while carjacking him which
led to an
accident in which he was fatally injured
well police said it we know
it's not just what police said we know
it happened because we saw it on video
and it led to an accident one of the
girls was stealing the car
and the man was standing there on the
ledge and ended up getting killed
but the reason you wrote the headline
this way cnn
is because it doesn't fit the narrative
in this case it was two black girls
killing this pakistani man this
pakistani american
and it doesn't fit the narrative and
that's why the story is important to
cover because
so much of our division and our hatred
is driven by a mainstream media that has
nothing to do
with journalism these people are not
journalists
and the problem for all of us that are
somewhat free thinking
and somewhat red pilled and somewhat
awake is what do we do
knowing that so many people are still
swallowing that nonsense
i don't know exactly what the answer is
but i'm really interested in finding it
out and i'm going to keep talking about
it
i want to show you one more thing this
is from axios this is the percentage of
americans who trust
traditional media from 2012 to 2021 so
you know roughly nine ten years
um it's dropped about ten percent
uh in that time so roughly from you can
see it's around fifty six percent
uh you know when this started in 2012
and now in 2021 it's at 46
that seems high to me trusted mainstream
media should be way lower than that
they should be about 20 it should be
about 20
and and i'd love to know more about that
that poll in and of itself
all right guys we did a lot here today
it's going to be a busy week
um oh and i don't want to say too much
because i don't know if this can be
fully public yet but i will be in new
york
city next monday one week from today
why would one be in new york city
one week from today interesting curious
you might say
guys part one of my interview with fox
meteorologist janice dean
who this truly i know i've done a lot of
interviews
uh it is one of the most enjoyable
interviews i've ever done she is just
such a fascinating woman and
what you may not know about her what
sort of put her on the map in the last
year
although she's been a meteorologist for
many many years is that her parents her
her
in-laws i should say uh both died of
covid after they were put back in
nursing homes by the order
from andrew cuomo and she went very
public about this and she's become just
an
absolute fighter and all-star and you
guys know i like people that fight i
like people that do
and there's a rumor out there that she
might even run for governor who knows
she's got a new book make your own
sunshine which is really spectacular we
talk about that but we mostly focus on
uh what's going on with the lockdowns
and cuomo
and just the terrible decisions that
have been made out of new york
so do check that out and actually the
full episode is already up at
reubenport.locals.com
all right guys i hope i gave you a
little something today you always give
me a little something
and uh i'll see you tomorrow bye